Save Sven.
I NEED TO SAVE SVEN.
HOW DO I SAVE SVEN?!
HOWDOIDOIT?!?!?!
*Satanic screaming*
(Subtitle by *I am HeRe *in description at bottom) aaaaaaaaaaaaaaaa
You be quiet.
You're disgusting.
I wish it was you down there and not him.
God
Ok we need dirt.
We need alotta dirt.
LOTTA DERT
We gotta ha-
build a tunnel
I DONT HAVE ALOTTA DIRT GODDAMNIT!
*moan*
Why do I not have dirt?
We will care... We will dig
We will dig
I'm going to need underwater breathing
oh god, Sven is there right now!
He must be so scared (Have you ever been stuck in water?)
Okay, Okay, Okay
I be meaning to do this for a long time
*click clack click clack click clack*
How do I make an enchantment table so I can breathe underwater?
Everyone's been saying it for three years
I need a book and diamonds
Oh god you know what, it doesn't care
I'll waste all my inventory if it means saving Sven
Ok and we need uhhh a book
okay, okay, okay
okay, okay gamers (GAMINGWEEEEK)
do do do do do, BUH!
Any second wasted here, is a second wasted
For Sven, the poor son of a.....
There it is, we have an enchantment table. What do I do with it?
I know I'm supposed to place it next to bookshelves
I DON'T HAVE ANY BOOKSHELVES
WHERE DO I PLACE IT?
let's put it here, let's put it here
WOAH that's cool
okay don't get distracted. How does it work?
that's the letharan teetis (what?) that I've been using for fricken dye, dude
are you kidding me?
what is this then? do I put a book there?
*gasps*
projectile protection?
no! I NEED UNDERWATER BREATHING
sharpness, protection, sharpness
NO! Give me! AHHH!
Feather falling
Efficiency
Smite!
THIS IS NOT HELPFUL!!!
Okay maybe I have some gear, maybe I have some gear
enchantment, projectile, curse of vanishing
What is this?!
We're losing time GODAMMIT!
Look I have a name tag and I was gonna name him and I never gave him his name tag
*Frantic noise*
project, uhhh, blast protection, fire
WHERE'S THE STUPID RESPIRATION HELMET?
we're just gonna dig
Joergen, I need you
We have to save him
Dig like the wind Joergen! (Like the wind?)
SHUUUT UUUPPPPPPP!
SHUUUUUT UUUUUPPPP! I DON'T CARE ABOUT FILTHY COWIE POOPIES
FASTER JOERGEN FASTER
WE NEED DIRT
LOT'S OF DIRT
You think that's dirt that you're digging right now?
oh zombies is not... I'm not going to sleep
I'm not going... AHHH JIBLET
GOD
*mumbles*
I'M DIGGING HERE
IS THERE NO WAY THAT YOU CAN DIG FASTER?
Joergen. oh my god this is faster without Joergen
get STOP RUNNING
dig, dig, dig, dig, dig *noises*
oh god okay I never wanted to do this
but I'm desperate goddammit
they could drop a helmet
that I can put on my face
and then I can breathe underwater
I'M SO SORRY TURTLE
I'M SO... OH GOD IT'S LOOKING AT ME I CAN'T DO IT
I can't do it
Sven would never want me to kill to save him
dig, dig dig
How much dirt do I need?
Is this enough?
oh god
SWIM
oh god it's so far away
I'm coming Sven
I'm coming to save... ow
oh god it's happening here too. What is this?
I'm getting sucked dude ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
stupid sucking almost ruined my life
Can dogs climb ladders? (Not usually)
Can I rope him up maybe?
Okay here we are gamers
Okay dirt, dirt
first let's make sure he's ok
gawd how did he get here?
how did this happen? (You rowed him out to see you dummy thicc)
Sven! Sven!
ohhh he doesn't even look at me
I'm so sorry Sven
I'm so sorry :-(
okay
okay, don't worry, don't worry, we're going to get you out of here
oh gawd ohhh
ok alright *noises*
oh god it's leaking Sven!
It's leaking Sven! I'm Panicking!
Ok alright oh god okay alright
oh god STUPID GRAVEL I HATE YOU YOU RUIN MY LIFE GRAVEL (seriously terrible)
Gotta be careful
If I die, Sven dies
How? How am I gonna do this?
they put a rocket in space gawdammit you can do this felix
oh god not now!
have another scooby snack (scooby-dooby-dooo!)
It's not going great. I'm not gonna lie, it's not going great
hold on Sven!
I'm just gonna go up one second
I meant it when I said it...
If anything happens to Sven, this playthrough is over! (Don't die Sven!)
BIGTIME
okay, okay, okay
the PLAN
You know what
I'm not even gonna waste time telling you :-(
'cause I need to get him out gosh harbit
Ride like the wind Joergen!
WE'RE COMING SVEN!
I don't have a spare lead for you
So we're going to have to use the good ol' hold technique
STAY THERE I BE RIGHT BACK
DUUUUUHHHHH
AH
he better be still in there
Where's Elon Musk when you need him?
I need his submarine!
Where's your submarine Elon?
OH GAWD NOT AGAIN I HATE THIS STUPID THING
Look the fishes have come to help.
They're here for moral support
thank you fishes (very cool!)
I'm trying my best here!
Okay so the idea is a little little little crazy
Okay alright
alright, you're okay, you're okay
oh gawd
alright
oh my god *happy noise*
I'm gonna need you to swim
ahwehf okay, alright
uhhhh
alright plan 'B', here
OH IT WORKS
Here we go
here we go
STAY RIGHT BEHIND ME
oh god this current. OH!
he can do it!
HE CAN DO IT!
come here!
YES
YES! WE'RE DOING IT!
THE FISHES ARE HELPING!
SWIM SVEN! SWIM SWIM SWIM SWIM
SWIM SWIM SWIM
HURRY HURRY HURRY HURRY
*EXCITED GASP*
Yeah! *HAPPY SQUEALS*
WE DID IT!
YEAHAHAHAESS
*SIGH OF RELIEF*
I'm so happy!
get up on the platform!
There's plenty of space! (x2)
Get up on the platform!
I was so scared Sven!
Get oop ahn the platform plzzzz
hallo!
alright, now we got 'em double safety
You ain't going nowhere
I got you now safe, and sound!
hey hey hey hey
oh god oh gawd
*noises*
Don't go anywhere!
We're returning home!
oh my god I'm so happy!
AAAAHHH NO NO NO NO NO
someone needs to mark that, that's terrible!
I know Sven, it's all over.
We did it!
Minecraft series, will continue! (Thank gawd!)
This whole show rests on your shoulders Sven
You can get out of the boat now
Alright, I'm putting you on a leash
Come here
Joergen you stayed!!
Joergen look who's here!
I know, it's Sven!
Okay, alright gamers
We're heading back home, it's getting dark. (It's already dark. (It's already dark, Felix)
Oh god, crippers
Did I lose my leash again?
why did I lose it?
There it is
oh, Sven!
DON'T HURT MY FRIEND!
Get away from Sven!
Are you just gonna sit there?
oh god- It's fine I get it, you've been busy
AHHH THEY GOT ARMOR AHHHH
Sven hurry!
Hurry we gotta make it back home!
OH GAWD IT'S GONNA BLOW UP
blow then!
*Swedish noises*
oh gawd
get, eat, sven stay stay
stay stay stay stay stay
oh NO
*sad music*
Sven?
AH oh thank god
oh I thought the bone was Sven!
*panting*
look, his tail is down, that means he's hurt!
We're going to have to get Joergen later!
Oh wait, he eats bones and stuff
we gotta get his health back
eat the bone
oh god he doesn't want to eat
Joergen, Please.
cooperation
I. THINK. NOT.
THOT
Ok it's safe, come
*kissy sound*
my child
eat somethign
*gasps* okay his tail is fine
come here Sven
ONLY I CAN KILL MY COWS
AHH
SVEN GET EM
ONLY I CAN KILL MY COWS
HURRY UP SVEN
that's it boi. good boi
good boi
come back
come in here sven
sven
sven please i cannot handle this any longer
SVEN
plz
come inside
we got scooby snacks
WE GOT SCOOBY SNACKS
THAT'S RIGHT WE GOT SCOOBY SNACKS
ok, sit, sit boi
there ya go
what is happening here?
oh, i got his tail
I'm going to sleep
Don't care what you say
*exhaling exhuberantly*
Oh i'm so stupid
It just hit me
about the enchantment
I know Sven I'm an idiot
obviously I was supposed to enchant a helmet
to make the helmet
you dumb shmuck, felix
so you just put, YES
underwa... UNBREAKING
AQUA INFINITY (AFFINITY, FELIX)
there you go gamers
it's as easy as 1,2,3
pee pee poo pee pee
here's something that we wanted to do for a long time Sven
I'm sorry I didn't do this sooner
thought I lost you
oh yeah, I gotta put the name on
*swedish?*
SVEN
My friend